with the disney plus debut of the falcon
and the winter soldier
sam wilson is set to take on a leading
role in the mcu
so there's no better time to find out a
little more about his comic book history
this is the untold truth of the falcon
the falcon first debuted in captain
america number 117
which was published all the way back in
1969. in this comic
sam wilson is a resident of harlem who
discovers that a group of hydra agents
led by the red skull are operating out
of a tropical island called exile
wilson and his trained falcon redwing
soon discover the group's nefarious plan
and along the way he learns that they've
been enslaving indigenous tribes on the
island
sam is then encouraged by captain
america himself
to adopt a superhero moniker of his own
and save the islanders
from the red skull's men artist gene
colen
had the idea for the falcon partly as a
response to the civil rights movement
and for a number of reasons he's
generally regarded as one of the more
empowering
characters of the silver age of comics
for one
he's arguably the first mainstream black
hero to not
actually have the word black in his name
falcon was also considered an equal to
captain america
rather than a sidekick and the two
famously received co-billing in the
ongoing captain america series for
almost 100 issues
despite receiving co-billing with cap
however it took a long time for falcon
to get a chance to shine in his own
series
indeed his origin story has been
retconned several times
and like many other comic book heroes
he's bounced between
several different teams over the years
falcon finally appeared as a solo act in
a 1979 issue of
marvel premiere a tryout series that the
company used to gauge
interest in new material although it
didn't lead to much
four years later he led a four-issue
mini-series that identified sam wilson
as a mutant
but that plot twist was wisely retconned
in 2001.
it wasn't until 2017 almost 50 years
after the character's debut
that the falcon got his own true solo
series the sensibly titled falcon
led by writer rodney barnes and artist
joshua casera
however as marvel fans will know wilson
led his own series a few years before
that
but it wasn't as the falcon at all
starting in 2014
sam wilson replaced his original partner
steve rogers as captain america
the transition occurs after rogers has
the super
soldier serum drained from his body
during a battle with iron nail
which forces him to hang up the shield
as he rapidly ages into an old man
considering how long the two had fought
side by side
wilson was a natural fit to take over
the role and continue
captain america's legacy this makes the
ending of avengers in-game even more
significant to longtime fans of the
comics
since both bucky barnes and sam wilson
have taken up the shield in the comics
it really could have been either of them
that filled steve rogers shoes
but while rogers and wilson do share a
knack for heroism
it will be interesting to see how the
falcon's totally different backstory
meshes with the role of captain america
in the mcu
for his mcu appearances falcon was given
a handful of technological
upgrades that fit with a more modern
interpretation of the character
in his original iterations however he
was pretty much just a dude in a costume
as his character started to gain a bit
more traction
certain elements were added for example
miniature solar arrays were inlaid into
the fiber
which allowed his suit to easily provide
its own power
in both the movies and later iterations
of the comics
falcon pilots a stark industry's drone
codenamed
redwing payload's secure
thanks sam don't thank me i'm not
thinking that thing
his name is red wing i'm still not
thinking he's cute
that's a far cry from his early years
though when he was partnered with an
actual trained falcon named redwing
falcon's origin
involves him forging a connection with
the bird who's been with the character
ever since that first issue of captain
america
and the two share a bond that goes far
beyond the emotional
it seems only right then that red wing
stays by falcon's side even when he
takes up captain america's shield
falcon has gone through a handful of
other technological upgrades over the
years too
his first modern costume was created at
captain america's request
not long after he made his debut and it
was even made by a familiar face
king t'challa of wakanda originally
black panther designed falcons wings to
have just a few basic features
including the solar receptors jet
boosters and a small handful of other
tricks and gizmos
over time however falcon has had
t'challa and a few others
upgrade his suit to give it the
versatility and power to rival marvel's
slickest heroes
one more recent iteration of the costume
features holographic wings made of hard
light
which feature a maximum wingspan of 50
feet
the wings can shield him from enemy
firepower they're virtually
indestructible
and they can be manipulated into a
variety of shapes and configurations at
the drop of a hat
all of this is controlled through a
cybernetic connection run through
falcon's mask
directly into his brain meaning the
whole system is controlled by his
thoughts
quite a leap from wings made of fabric
receipt for your gear
bird costume come on i didn't write it
falcon's origin story has been changed a
few different times
but one thing has remained constant he
was originally a relatively ordinary man
with no superpowers to speak of
still when he fights alongside redwing
in his debut story
the connection between wilson and his
avian ally seems abnormally strong
but it later turns out that the red
skull himself
helped give this power to wilson as part
of a plot that revolved around a very
familiar marvel macguffin
the cosmic cube in a later story it's
revealed that the red skull
used the cosmic cube to brainwash wilson
into turning against captain america
an act which also established a
telepathic link between the falcon and
redwing
as he grows into his role as falcon
wilson learns to expand this
link and what begins merely as a means
of communication
soon becomes the ability to see through
red wings eyes
eventually wilson becomes able to see
through any bird's eyes
and even access their memories but the
falcons encounter with the cosmic cube
had other side effects as well
one of which would lead to a very
unfortunate retcon
the confusing nature of comic books can
mean some characters are given many
backstories
since so many different writers are
involved in such a wide shared universe
some pretty strange contradictions and
retcons can emerge if you go back
far enough and despite falcon enjoying a
pretty strong debut
his character was later given a new and
immensely disappointing
origin in his original story falcon is a
social worker from harlem
that background was overturned in a
later run however in which it is
revealed that sam wilson's true
identity is snap wilson a harlem mobster
in pimp
who is essentially the epitome of an
ugly racial stereotype
his social worker origen is explained to
have been a false memory
implanted in wilson's mind as a side
effect of the cosmic cube's powers
fast forward a few decades to 2015 and
it turns out that the snap
wilson origin was the actual false
memory
implanted by red skull to so confusion
in the falcon's mind
wilson's life as a social worker is
subsequently revealed to be the real
memory
having simply been overwritten by the
power of the cube
comics love to critique satirize and
subvert
things that are happening in the real
world and falcon has tackled his fair
share of real world issues too
one of the strangest instances of this
occurred during a brief avengers run
that began in 1979
when wilson joined the team and quit
almost immediately
at this point in time the united nations
liaison for the avengers is a man
named henry geyrich who tasks captain
america with recruiting falcon to join
the team
however falcon learns that guy rich has
merely tapped him to fill a racial
hiring quota
and he isn't best pleased falcon has
come and gone from a variety of teams
over the years
but he has almost always stayed true to
his convictions
as a character he believes in being
recognized for a person's skills and
abilities
and his principle in quitting a group
like the avengers due to being a token
hire
epitomizes that belief in many ways sam
wilson was the one who helped steve
rogers heal from the grief of losing his
old partner
bucky barnes when it is revealed that
bucky has been alive all along
albeit having been brainwashed into
becoming a soviet assassin
wilson is there for rogers as they try
to help barnes regain his memories their
dynamic in the mcu
is a little different than in the comics
as in the movies
the falcon and captain america don't
have half a century's worth of history
together
in the comics however a mutual respect
is earned between
sam and bucky not just because of their
relationship with cap
but because they both spent time
carrying the shield when roger stepped
aside
there weren't many story lines that
really explored this relationship
properly though until the 2020 falcon
and winter soldier series that is
when the series picks up falcon is back
in the bird suit and bucky has received
a pardon for his murderous past but is
contingent on working for an agency that
locates
and eliminates domestic terrorists the
series forces
wilson and barnes together as they try
to track down
baron zemo as well as a handful of other
villains including the natural
a psychotic teenage assassin with a
captain america fetish
over time the series deepens their
friendship and allows both to evolve as
heroes
much like the upcoming disney plus
series as poised do
not too much is known about the disney
plus falcon and winter soldier series so
far
as marvel and disney have been typically
tight-lipped about what to expect
but one or two details are certain at
least oh yeah i can see it working
gear's turning oh they're malfunctioning
they're on fire
most importantly both anthony mackie and
sebastian
stan will be continuing in their
respective roles of sam wilson and bucky
barnes
joined by returning mcu stars emily van
camp
who plays sharon carter and daniel
brewell as the nefarious baron zemo
joining the cast is wyatt russell who is
taking on the role of john walker
the u.s government approved replacement
for steve rogers
with wilson having been handed captain
america shield at the end of avengers
end game
it seems certain that the show will
focus on wilson's transition from the
falcon to the new captain america
the series was created and written by
malcolm spellman who is best known for
writing several episodes of the tv
series
empire very few details are known about
the falcon in the winter soldiers plot
but it isn't all that hard to figure out
which comic books have inspired the
series story
especially considering where the
characters ended up after avengers end
game
the most likely route for the show to
take would involve borrowing beats from
the captain america sam
wilson run in 2015 captain america
fought that battle with the iron nail
which led to his rapid aging and
subsequent retirement from his life as a
superhero
rogers then passes the mantle to sam
wilson who has to cope with the
responsibilities of becoming captain
america
in light of the similar circumstances at
the conclusion of endgame
this storyline seems a likely influence
on the series
beyond that though anything could happen
but considering the involvement of so
many villains and anti-heroes
including baron zemo john walker batrack
the leaper
and flagsmasher you can be sure of at
least one thing
sam wilson and bucky barnes are gonna
have their hands full
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one